you
[Music]
so these certain is about human
perception I think many people are
working in AI and I started to do
perception of machine perception by food
cameras microphones etc and so I invited
a series of neuroscientists here today
to talk a bit about human perception one
of the reasons we want to talk about
human perception is because if you look
at the devolution of Earth and organisms
in Earth humans are the last ones to
appear and it seems like we have the
most complex sensory systems so what's
interesting if we look at the timeline
of organisms most of the time was
actually spent going from unicellular
organisms to very primitive blurry
cellular organisms that were not diverse
and all of a sudden something happens
that we start having a lot of diversity
and that the speed of evolution
increases dramatically and that's
precisely the moment in which organisms
start to be able to sense exterior so
praise consider predators predators
consider preys they need to run faster
they need to evolve get update 3 or
things like that get out of the water
and if when we look at computing if to
me it looks very similar we just had
computers for a very long time and now
we're starting to see self-driving cars
or assisted the talking assistants or
you know we're selling the CDs
diversifies form of computing which is
very based on input sensors and
responses so what we have here today is
a series of neuroscientists who are
working on different types of sensory
perception
important party so some of the sensory
perception so we're not only visual
animals were multi-sensory animals and I
will start with another Hedorah it's our
first speaker today and he has worked
for many years already in the field of
auditory perception and producing
illusions so we will learn a bit more of
how humans compute the audio signals and
how can we play with that
so yeah my name is Hannah a thank you
much for putting together this in person
and the Microsoft for this great
opportunity to be here today so I'm
going to talk about the auditory system
and like very sensory systems a elision
main function is to monitor a certain
environment in order to obtain
information about things that are
happening around us and alert us of
significant events that require an
action from our side this allows to keep
a constant margin of safety and also to
guide our axioms and if we think about
keeping a constant margin of safety a
lesion has several and has several
advanced advanced ideas with respect to
other sensory systems and for that
reason it is often known as a warning
system so forest an algorithm provides
with a continuous stream of information
because our yes never turn off in the
same way that vision - for example when
we close our eyes or when we look away
it is considered to be a change the
texture with high temporal resolution
and high sensitivity for structure
motion this cookie audience our behavior
it can inform out events occurring all
around us even those that are outside
our visual field of view and process
realize streams of information in
parallel and also occurs in some ways
reflect on the walls and returns our
ears with a lesion we can get a pretty
good impression of geometry and size of
the space where we are in so for
instance a when I studied videos
different simulations of acoustic
environments and people were quite hood
differentiate them when we hear an
object only based on the sound we can
get quite enough informational
properties of these objects so I want to
play you one at some fun
you
okay so I guess have many of you a hot
gas and this is a round object also I
have a hot material maybe some of you
realize Delta T's has mole object and I
had a soft and smooth on a smooth
surface given the object
okay so only based on sound we can
identify objects and events and with
this information we can attribute them
and significance levels but not only
that we found a we also in Austin
informational about where with respect
to us these events are happening and
that will have an influence how
significant we would perceive incidents
to to be so for instance a we did some
work so in that some sources that are
perceived as being closer to our body
who approach in our body or behind our
body elicit more arousing experiences
than the counterparts because they are
more significant to us so they get our
body more ready for action and think
return even more interesting when we
consider the sounds do solids
Donna fuel in isolation there are other
sensory inputs that we receive at the
same time and we need to consider a
cross model effects some sensory
modalities interact I've got you a
couple of examples that maybe some of
you know so I guess that a the majority
of you are seen two balls that are
crossing they are passing by but if I
add sound to this
many some of the universe's than the two
of these are bouncing there's also a
dissolution Department a skinny Lucia so
if you ask people to grab their hands so
you produce this sound and you alter the
frequency spectra of these sounds you
can give people the impression of having
a smoother skin or more dry skin so our
perception is multi-sensory
which allows us to have meaningful -
sexual experiences and to form coherent
representations of the eternal world
with the sensory integration is central
to adaptive behavior because most of the
time leads to more advanced behaviors so
we get for example is motor reaction
times is knowledge detection threshold
so for example we'll have the DISA study
in which people were asked to to match
the intensity level of a proton to a
reference tone and then they were asked
to do the same but when when they were
holding a tube that was vibrating at the
same frequency than the sound and in the
situation it was shown that people
actually heard the sound as being
loudest that why the study was called a
handheld game sometimes we will get
discrepant information from the
different senses and sometimes this
leads to the calibration processes
awesome
we trust more one of the sensory
modality so for example it is often
assumed that with Raz more visual system
for a special task and the literary
system system for temporal task but this
doesn't mean that they don't interact
with each other and bias each other and
when we have learned from sensory
studies is that actually one cannot
predict multi sensory perception by
studying senses in isolation so in our
lab where I study multi sensory
perception and we are focusing in a very
specific case of multi sensory
perception which is body perception
imagining body project we are using
sound for altering one's body perception
and also looking at influences on motor
behavior and emotion so our research
draws from neuroscience works on body
representations and by volley represent
and I mean this sense that everyone has
a how their body looks like and also
where the body parts are in this place
we now know that this body
representation is not fixed it is
continuously updated so that sensory
input that we receive from environment
and we also know that this sense of
bodies buried representation is crucial
for emotional state for motion and
social interactions so we can actually
manipulate sensory inputs and give
people the impression of having a
different body we have for example the
sample the example of the body so
ablution in order to music solution what
you will do is that you use this kind
multi-display and people see from a
third-person perspective a Monica's body
if you start at in both bodies in
synchrony what people read is this
impression that okay I'm seeing these
mannequins believe in that and at the
same time I think that my own body so
this must be my body
you can induce the similarly illusion by
having bodies of different sizes so you
can do it with the alien body with a
Barbie doll body and which is what is
interesting here is that after being in
the Barbie doll body people start
experiencing everything around as being
huge and also if you so people are not
yet and you ask them to close their eyes
and work until reaching this object they
will work for a longer time after
winning the Barbie doll body than after
being in the giant body assuming that
because they have smaller legs they need
to work for longer time so this Italian
other study seems to to suggest that our
body is used as a perceptual ruler so if
I perceive my body as being very big I
will perceive objects as being a small
and and also being closer to me and that
will influence my subsequent behavior so
before we start with a hidden body
project in 2012 there were evidences
that you can manipulate for
representation and avoid representation
by sending a visual test and a group
effective use when there was no evidence
of the effects of sound body
representation and at that point we
thought okay we wondering that we
surpassed
when you that objects you produce lots
of sounds that are actually written
information about the body so here s an
example so the sound that I produce when
i when i tap with my hand on a surface
has information of where my hand is in
the space and therefore how long my arm
is or the sound of my footsteps will be
different if i have a small body with I
have a big body
so what will happen if we manipulate
this sensory cues these sounds will be
we will we induce the sensation of
having a different body so we have been
collecting evidences of the effects of
manipulating this sounds on the
represented body and here are some
examples that I'm going to tell you
about
so we manipulated tapping sounds in a
series of experiments what we did is
that we as people to tap on the floor
and different points they were not
allowed to do cannon hunt when they were
tapping and every time and date that
they heard a tapping sound in the sea
delicious condition this tapping sound
originated on the same location where
they were tapping so it was a natural
situation when we had a double distance
conditioning which they were tapping and
they survey the sound that happens sound
originated at the vendor distance so if
they were tapping 75 centimeters away
the sound was one and a half meters away
we also had a quadruple distance
condition another one distant I think
ranae's condition in which we introduced
as more delay between the tapping action
and a tapping sound in order to disrupt
a multi-sensory integration so this was
our control condition so we have
participants a tapping and for periods
of 1 minute in one of these of these
conditions and before and after we had a
method of how long they perceive them to
be
so what we did is that we presented two
tactile points to all the participants
and we asked them to estimate the
distance between these two points which
will be related to how long they
perceive them to be
and Here I am presenting the results of
the purple nation so is the change in
Titleist entitlements from before to
after adaptation I'm gonna sell weed and
there was only a significant change for
the Darwin distance condition in that
condition after the lab station people
perceive the distance between the two
points to be bigger which mainly related
to to have a long run and actually NASA
sequence a study with other nice changes
in catalyst and judgments correlated
with the subjective feeling of arm
elongation in another study we also saw
that there were changes in kinematics of
rigid movements or movements after the
lava distance condition were performed
in a way consistent with having a longer
arm so let me tell you now about the
study that we did with footstep sounds
so we want interested in this type of
sounds because they are very rich in
information about people's bodies so
think for example about my situation
where you are walking down the street
and you hear someone walking behind you
without looking at this person you can
already tell me a number of things
around the body of the person so for
example you may say something on the
postage of the worker also it is a male
woman and also you can get approximately
the size of the shoe of this person
these judgments are based on the fact
now heavier bodies produce sounds with
no one frequency mode than lighter
bodies at the smaller bodies and
listeners are actually quite good in
picking up on these skills one estimated
properties of the worker body the person
when they are not looking at but what
happens with our own footstep sounds do
they also inform how our own body and
what will happen if we change them so in
order to explore this question what we
did is that we build a system that allow
us to change in real time the sequence
instead of the working sounds and
feedback and feedback to two people that
sounds like headphones with this system
we also had a sensor that allow us to
measure gait and emotional state which
we thought I will be related to the
changes in perceive the body wave so
here we have a photo of our prototype
where you can see
now we have a microphone scintillating
there for sensitive resistors and
accelerometers and we ask people to walk
down this corridor in one of these three
conditions so in the control condition
with manipulating the footstep sounds
and then we have high and low frequency
conditions remember that the rationale
for these conditions is that we know the
heavier bodies produce sounds with
higher frequency mode than lighter
bodies and I've wrote a video so that
you can get a feeling of the impression
that people gain the system and the word
resistance also in the background and
you will hear the sounds in the three
conditions
yeah
so as I said in the Ferryman's people
walk down the corridor while we monitor
their gait the emotional responses that
we also monitor with her question and at
the end of the corridor we are going to
use this avatar so what we ask them is
to change the dimensions of the avatar
so that it correspond to their own body
dimensions and with this we got a method
of the perceive body way and what we
found in the studies is that a
augmenting the high frequencies of cell
produce working sounds results in people
perceiving the Warriors lighter in a
more positive and arouse feeling faster
and more able to localize the feet we
also found that they were Tennessee in
gait so in the high frequency condition
people have spent less time in contact
with the floor and they also accelerated
more the legs when lifting the the food
from the floor so they did more exercise
in this condition and still they
reported being happier and these medical
societies because the sign is related to
an enhanced emotional state and a better
position for physical activity so we
continue collecting
they turn this direction in this project
and also employers with people with
chronic pain thinking that designing
certain opportunities to design audio
bass voice haunted applications to
support well-being the aim of these
applications would be to make people
feel good about their beliefs and
motivate them towards physical activity
and we are now working in this project
in which we are exploring the potential
of using some feedback to change a
sedentary lifestyle but let me tell you
now the another series of studies so
until now I have been talking about how
we manipulated axial sounds to to change
the represented body but how about non
action sounds sounds that do don't
naturally approve put the OSHA's in the
representation of our body so in order
to investigate this we can study which
we just don't a rising or falling in
peace and we look at whether these
stones could alter the length of the
represented body path we call this the
auditory Pinocchio because it reminds us
so this pricing volume pitch sounds
remind us of the sounds that are often
used in the cartoons of Pinocchio so is
the sound that accompanies a narrowing
of the nose indeed we chose these sounds
because there is a well known capacity
of changes in pitch to elicit in
presence of motion and changing of their
size so we thought that maybe they will
also change
body size and in our experiments what we
did is I would call a participant hunt
and then we are going to pull on the
finger and every time that they pull on
the finger that triggered a one of these
three sounds so we had a an accident oh
sorry too loud sorry for that soloist
Anita stone - in tow
or a post on tone okay so after hearing
the sound we asked people to use two
sliders to indicate what was the cell
position of the single tip and the third
position of the knuckle so with that we
obtained a method of estimating finger
length and we also with that after the
ascending tone condition people
estimated the singer leg has been longer
than in the other conditions we also had
a questionnaire in which we asked people
to choose a drawing from a series of
nine and we saw that at the resonant
tone condition people chose a drawing
with a longer finger than in the air
conditions so we have seen in this
presentation that people research has
found that body representation is
flexible that can be modified by visual
and tactile cues I also gave you some
examples of how it can be manipulated
with sound but most of these examples
are often realistic so the the partner
without an effect with an arbitrary
cessation with a sound so how really we
are to refer available information to
ourself and you have to conclude in this
presentation I have been telling you
about how human perception is
multi-sensory and plastic a
multi-sensory integration is centered
the lapped in behavior so we believe
that a studies of medicinal in person
multi sensory perception can inform the
design of intelligent systems has come
for molecular representations of the
world and activator I have been telling
you around a specific example of body
representation and how it depends on
auditory analysis or information so in
Supra model at changes in body
representation connect to changes in
behavior and emotions with devatta
quite a nice framework to the study body
representation I even if I have been
talking mainly our body perception in
our studies and other studies we have
seen a similar principles apply also to
objects obvious perception
during body object interactions so this
is a surface interaction sound that we
produce with a obvious
can also tear of the representation and
influence motor behavior and emotion so
we can talk in terms of essentially
motor looks so when we act we learn now
what accidents and we have some
predictions of what is going to to be
the sensory output and if there are some
discrepancies between our predictions
and the output will actually adapt to
our behavior to minimize those
discrepancies so that with that I finish
I would like to thank you for your
attention and also thank you all the
people that made this work possible and
our funders so I think the questions
will be in a banana yeah okay so thank
you Anna this was fantastic and I think
all of your next we will leave the
questions for the end because we're
going to have different sensory
modalities and I think because of the
multi-sensory nature we probably gather
more questions across and so on a
blanket our next speaker is coming from
FFL he has been working on body
perception from visual perspective also
manipulations from the visual tactile or
multi modality beyond auditory also he
has publications in science important
journals so I think it's very relevant
also for the understanding of human
perception so on
I thanks mark for the for the
introduction also the invitation and and
organizing this symposium I think I just
have to stick this here and so what I
what I would like to talk about it
continued on multi-sensory integration
and perception but talk more about the
issue of consciousness the neuroscience
of consciousness in particular and again
talk about a multi-sensory version of
consciousness and in particular how this
neuro scientific model can account for
the subject of experience which has
mostly been excluded from standard
consciousness studies and I'll give a
few examples about this something that's
dear to my heart and I think and you've
heard already some ik examples before
and also of male the next speaker it's
experience engineering so this is really
virtual reality augmented reality but
also robotics and haptics technologies
in order really to apply engineering
principles and neuroscience principles
to the problem of human consciousness
and then the last point what I would
like to discuss and propose to you today
is that artificial intelligence should
maybe not target many of the things not
only target of course many of the things
we've heard about cognitive aspects of
the mind but also another important
aspect of the mind namely that the mind
is is is conscious and I will not tell
you any anything new but perception
language learning memory whether it's
targeted by eye eye or whether you open
it a classical textbook of of cognitive
neuroscience these are very much in the
forefront and in main domains of what is
targeted today and we've seen also over
the days however as I said before what
about consciousness can i i target
consciousness and of course the
cognitive neurosciences of these
functions are based on over a century of
research but also consciousness has
consciousness research has matured quite
a lot that's 40 years of research now
I'll give you a brief introduction just
very brief introduction about that so
what is consciousness consciousness in a
very simple format subjective experience
so when I'm having a thought or when I'm
in pain I'm not just having pain I'm
also there is something it is like to be
in that state it's quite fearful pain
maybe a bit less clear already for
thinking but also when we have a visual
perception when we have an auditory
perception there's something it is like
if we are for example doing the foot
step that anna has just talked to us
about i'm not just hearing or my brain
is not just processing it it is really
my footstep that i'm hearing at that
moment and why do i show you this little
bit of esoteric kind of picture here
there's yet another interesting aspect
about this consciousness because we all
know we're living in a physical universe
there is only objective effects out
there yet there is this first-person
givenness of these perceptual state off
the pain so they it seems to be if as a
philosopher and conceptually we think
about it seems just to be no place for
the subjective first-person state it's a
senseless universe and third-person
synonymous that we can physically
describe so where is this subjective
evidence coming from and don't worry
that's about as philosophical as as well
as it will get and this is again nothing
new because these gentlemen have
discussed it for several centuries and
what what is really happening now is
that this problem of philosophy and it
is of course a very interesting one it's
turning or has turned into a real
empirical scientific challenge we now
have methods and we want to understand
this and bring this problem of
consciousness to the research lab and
link it to these different brain
mechanisms so what is about this level I
talked about visual perception so what
is a good example to to give you very
briefly in those twenty a minutes one
example of what visual consciousness can
be this is the phenomena of blind sight
that you may have that you may have
heard about so there is a surgical
resection of this full of a tumor and in
this patient a very famous patient Gy
and so what happens is his visual field
if you present stimuli visual stimuli
all sorts of different stimuli in this
blackened part of the visual field he
will tell you I don't see but if you ask
the patient Gy to guess he's better than
chance so he has something that we all
don't have a dissociation he doesn't see
can perform perceptual visual perceptual
judgments that are correct
and so he has two kind of levels of
consciousness if you want consciousness
is absent here visual consciousness but
in the white part of the visual field
it's it's maintained there's other ways
so this is a decrease the loss of visual
consciousness if you want wild
perception is maintained in this example
also typical way how visual
consciousness is studied under the lab
we're enhancing visual consciousness so
this is a visual illusion by by a tail
tune from from MIT and although you have
to believe my word for it you can you
can you can try for yourself you find
many images on the web that this gray
square is the same brightness as this
gray square so the a and the B are put
on the same kind of level of off
darkness and of course this is related
to the fact that the grain is of this
it's very much dependent on what is
surrounding it white squares here
darkish squares here and also the shade
that you have in here but what the
important notion is here I won't go into
detail is that this is an elevation or
it's a different state visual
consciousness and hence in the sense
that there is an illusory state because
we clearly perceived it as not being the
same so subjectively again there's a
change in this is really these beautiful
illusions that you can see here these
lines horizontal lines are all straight
these two lines are the same size and
really there is really not a triangle
that is that is shown here again the
idea of having a range of visual
illusions and how we empirically target
this is through of course brain imaging
methods at the same time giving us in
healthy subjects not just in patients
dissociations between visual
consciousness and let's say visual
perceptual mechanisms and again what I
would like to discuss today is well can
artificial intelligence target also
these differences not just visual
perception discriminating different
faces but making differences in
predictions between visual consciousness
and a differently conscious state
however and this is now coming to work
of my own lab we're working on rather
multi-sensory consciousness because
visual consciousness is just
in particular domain as we've heard just
a many beautiful example auditory
consciousness may be something
altogether different and then there's
tactile gustatory and so on
consciousness things get worse and
already these guys the card lock on Hume
could have told us this consciousness is
not just visual it's multi-sensory and
it's integrated it's also unitary
experiences these experiences for me and
comes in again this kind of esoteric
supposedly as a Tareq topic there is a
subject of conscious experience these
are conscious experiences for me again
that visual illusion I saw is a visual
illusion for myself and this I think
this this picture of ourselves is nicely
so we're not in the lab interested so
much about what I'm looking at
we're more interested at who is this
entity that's looking out and who is
holding this mirror this round sphere
ignore in his left left hand so what is
the self of conscious experience more or
the subject of experience more than the
object of this experience and we've
studied this using a range of other
illusions that we have adapted so this
is a video called the rubber hand
illusion and there's a hidden hand that
you will see on the left sides of the
subject cannot see and then there is
this ridiculously looking fake hand in
plain view and this hand which receives
the stroking cannot be seen mediated by
prop receptors touch and the visual hand
is shown here let me play this again
this is so nice and I always get the
question how do you get epics for this
that's don't don't ask me now maybe in
the in the in the next round but what is
really important there is two hands or
there's three hands actually about two
left hands this hand here is receiving
the tactile stroking and cannot be seen
and he gets proper scepter for
information and this ridiculously
looking hand here it's getting visual
stroking but at the same time and what
what the experiment does in this short
time is creating an association visual
information overrides bad or poor there
was a beautiful demo we saw at the
headquarters at the Microsoft Research
earlier
visual information overrides the proper
separation
and the touch queue is important so that
two stimuli arrive at the same time
again the timing being very important
for this multi-sensory illusion and
you've seen the threat comes clearly
from the right side but it didn't that
doesn't pull away the right hand he's
pulling away too far hand actually
because there's this association that is
created but again so how can you reuse
this illusion and I should say this
illusion only works if the stroking is
applied at the same time the stroking is
applied to the delay it won't happen and
how we approach this or you apply this
illusion is in order to target a subject
of conscious experience we wanted to
have a more global unitary form so we
applied stroking we had a VR set up a
video set up in India in the back or a
subject was standing straight was
wearing a head mounted display and when
we turned the video camera on obviously
you would see the film body from the
back view you would see this as the body
standing in in front of you and then
what we did is we applied vijnana was
actually doing the work we apply the
touch cue here so you would feel the
touch here but you would see the touch
at an avatar two meters in front of you
so there's a very similar setup with a
hidden hand on the left side and their
individual hand and in straight view so
the visual body the virtual body is now
here and and the tactile body if you
want was for shown here and you do this
for its certain while and you can see
this this set up here again the subject
is fill it with a head-mounted display
then this is what you would see on a
head mounted display and you would you
would see as you can see here the
stroking applied although physically you
receive it on your back so very much
similar like the rubber hand illusion we
initially thought to call this rubber
body illusion but a quick quick search
on the web we found all sorts of strange
websites so so we really cited to stick
to F F full-body losing in the sense but
it was really important here is that by
using this illusion we're not only
changing what the brain believes to
belong to me to this entity but it
changes not where my hand is in space
with respect to a stable trunk but it
changes when my brain localizes the
center of awareness my mind my body in
space this is shown on this
left image here so if after the illusion
the subject has been standing has
received the stroking the eyes are
closed and we displace and passively
there's other forms of task and we ask
them to walk back to the position where
they have been standing they walk too
far they walk towards the position of
the avatar rather with a fake body if
you want the visual fake body then the
real body this is this recalibration
here of where the brain believes that
the center of awareness is so the
subject of experience in our model and
again if the stroking is not applied
synchronously meaning if I see the
stroking at another moment when I feel
the stroking at my back
this recalibration breaks down we can
also measure subjectively people
identify is the body that you're looking
at do you feel that this is your body
this is this question here question
three question one is related so we can
also induce changes expert such a
subjective changes but also these
automatic bodily recalibration so we as
scientists can better predict where a
subject calculates the center of
awareness of subjective experience then
the subject him or herself this comes
with these are other experiments we've
done using the same setup so this comes
also with consequences for how the brain
represents the participants body you
could see for example here in the
illusion inducing condition whether it's
this positional recalibration body
temperature cools down so it's a small
degree but you can see already after 40
seconds of exposure body temperature is
going down and you endure also more pain
if you measure pain thresholds doing
this illusion the more you identify with
the other body the less warm your body
is and the more pain you endure so we
are continuing this this line of work
but one particular aspect I wanted to
show very important for us at
neuroscientist is to see which brain
mechanisms would be involved so we had
to to build this robotic device inside
the that works inside the scanner the
highly constraining environment I don't
know how familiar you are with with with
the scanner but it's a pretty standard
scanner meaning you have about two feet
of diameter where you have to fit these
robotic devices and as you can see here
the same kind of stroking at the back
while you see
and avatar receiving the stroking above
or in an elevated position from you
attending deuce first of all the same
illusory state but we can then also
measure in this first study here the
brain mechanisms reflecting those
changes and what we are able to see is
that these two regions here on the left
and right temporoparietal Junction and
also this large extended network is a
network that can be selectively
activated if there is a change not in
perception but a change in this self
conscious feeling so the center of
awareness again an idea and a mechanism
that I think would be interesting to
study with a method of artificial
intelligence so what happens if that
same brain system I just described to
you it's not disruptive by a virtual
reality but by brain damage you actually
get something that we we can predict now
you get so called of out-of-body
experiences so the center of awareness
is calculated at another position in
space now we can clearly predict this
and what is happening in such cases is
that although the physical body is a
position a here there's a position B
where the brain calculates where the
center of awareness is imagine you're
wearing a head mounted a display or
you're sitting in front of your computer
working you would be at a position or
the brain would calculate the location
to me at a 2 meter distance we were
actually able to see in one study that
there is one particular location very
close if you have damage to this region
very close to the activity and healthy
subjects that have to just describe to
you in one particular case that where we
could observe that by stimulation at
these two yellow lesion sites in a
patient suffering from the
pharmacologist and epilepsy induces for
two seconds of stimulation these missed
calibrations so out-of-body experiences
where the patient believes to be under
the ceiling and to be looking back down
to the physical body so as if the
stimulation induces a phenomena that we
have used or created basically used
based on virtual reality so are these
just pathological experiences not at all
actually I think the out-of-body
experience is something very similar to
phantom phantom limb sensations I show
you one example here in a write up a
limp amputee there is a
and that is perceived as being present
although the hand physically is on the
arm the forearm is gone so out-of-body
experience are supernumerary phantom not
a supernumerary phantom limb but a
supernumerary phantom body the brain has
the capacity and actually has on a
continuous basis has to calculate where
the center of awareness is it is not a
given that our centre of awareness or
subjective experience should be in our
head or in electron position Celia
Greene has studied already over 400
cases quite a while ago and I thought I
mentioned just here at this at this
conference that Marvin Minsky has
actually also had an out-of-body
experience he suffered from migraine and
of course already at 17 he knew
everything there was to know about about
migrants at his own very clear
hypothesis what what had had happened
it's it's quite an interesting personal
account so he was not scared of those
sensations but most people tend to be
quite scared if they happen for the
first time so again consciously I can
target I think these differences between
subjective consciousness and and and
unconscious States with respect to the
self there is even an animals now
sufficient data of which systems about
the strong multi-sensory integration
where they are located what kind of
signals and they prefer there is
actually not just between monkeys and
humans but also in rodents quite quite
interesting data now and these these
data are s precise are starting to
become s precise as we have them also
for visual perception so again all the
reason to for for artificial
intelligence I think to go into this
field and do the really interesting work
on the foundations of consciousness let
me let me conclude so first again I
talked to you about the neuroscience of
consciousness or of a particular form of
of multi-sensory consciousness not so
much about the hand example that I've
given to you but our work focuses mostly
on a more global unitary form which is
where's my body in this in space and not
where's my arm my right or my left arm
with respect to a stable trunk so what
are the mechanisms counting or
calculating
a sensory awareness and the conscious
experience of being a particular person
I think we need to have much better tech
tools for for experience engineering and
on the next slide I propose one
collaboration may be that good could
move forward so robotics that we're also
doing in the lab quite a lot together
with optics is one way plus plus virtual
reality but I the main part here the
main argument is here that we this ghost
in the machine that we all carry within
us and that marvelously we never or
hardly get it wrong to locate the
conscious being within our bodily bodily
representations that are created by the
brain I think that artificial
intelligence should embrace next to
these cognitive aspects really this
notion of bodily self-consciousness that
I've presented it is the most important
but also the most fascinating aspect of
consciousness I find the personal state
but I think we are currently pursuing to
get more stronger and more persistent
state of these alterations I think what
needs to happen that instead of these 1
or 2 minutes exposures to to these
multi-sensory stimulations
either with systems that are available
here but also in other forms we should
have prolonged exposures so we are
experimenting with the drone setup where
there is also a mixed reality setup
where these states can maybe approach
potentially not just avatar illusions
but true out-of-body experience another
idea would be can we be embodied and
feel self-conscious for several
locations we're all used and live our
entire lives just having one stable self
location what about projecting self
footstool to several bodies and of
course I think which I didn't want to
forget to mention here that the neuro
inspiration I think is very important we
may not have to recreate everything that
is necessary as long as these critical
neurological mechanisms are involved and
then for the whole field of
consciousness apart from self
consciousness I think we really as a
field of neuroscience have to work
closely together
just you know there's very basic
questions that are unanswered so of
course we know that the brain is
relevant for consciousness but how can
it be that not of which are the parts
that are most relevant the cerebellum
for example the back of the head carries
contains more than 50% of the neurons
but you can lose all of those and you
still have normal levels of
consciousness can other species have
have consciousness like an octopus here
or when our babies or when our children
fully conscious to an adult level how
much does this take and of course the
main problem here is that we as
researchers in neuroscience have is we
can't ask either babies nor other
animals very important for unfor being
sure that Mel and I also have
consciousness that is comparable to mind
sure they look like me sure they behave
like me but I can ask them and all these
these methods are not available in
animals so I think again artificial
intelligence with language intelligence
would be would be very interesting and
of course a very big question may be a
bit too from my second philosophical
point can machines be conscious so
imagine we would have a machine that has
a self conscious representation based on
the standards and highly comparable to
to animal and human data would we have
to give those would we have to call
those machines conscious and then
clinical applications are really as a
last light here there is many clinical
applications where artificial
intelligence could really help and give
quantitative data for this to predict
whether patients are in a coma or not
conditions where there's too much
consciousness think about schizophrenia
and hallucinations where diagnosis is
still based on verbal interactions
between a psychiatrist and a patient
today I think quite shocking and I think
I stop here and I thank you for your
attention
[Applause]
Thank You Olaf he was very interesting
they were next welcoming me later men's
work has he has been working with
virtual reality and technologies to
produce the solutions of multi sensory
illusions inside better reality for
quite some decades already and I think
lately he's also being focused quite a
lot on behavior so I think also in AI
once we're able to process all this
sensory perception maybe even have a
consciousness then I get the next thing
is behavior and it's working perfect so
I will just leave it with men and thank
you Thanks thanks to my thanks also for
inviting inviting me because it made me
think about some new things that wasn't
thinking about before so I'm going to be
talking about apparently something
completely different you diminishing
racial bias using virtual reality but
actually as your see it's really the
same so I'm going to start with this
which may be uncomfortable for some
people here which is a Microsoft chat
box named Jay calls the sensation this
is a report from the BBC a chat box
developed by Microsoft has gone rogue on
Twitter swearing and making racial
racist remarks etc here's something from
CNN after racist tweets Microsoft
muzzles teen chat box take the verge
this is for me the the funniest one
twitter twitter taught Microsoft ai chat
box to be a racist blah blah in less
than a day
but the question I want to consider is
how are we going to take this is also
from the verge how are you going to
teach AI using public data without
incorporating the worst traits of
humanity so this is the issue I want to
address I'm not going to give an answer
but that's what I want to address and
I'm going to approach this not from an
AI perspective but from an embodied
virtual reality perspective and that may
have some interest for AI so the outline
of the talk is that first I'm going to
very briefly recap some of the things
that the previous speakers have said the
idea of a plastic brain and body
ownership then I'm going to talk about
the consequences of body transformation
illusion and then some experiments in
racial bias and then a neural network
model that helps to describe some of the
data that we found and then some
conclusions so from another way to think
about a body ownership illusion which
both previous speakers have spoken about
is that it usually occurs when there's
multi-sensory data that involves a
contradiction that the brain results by
producing the illusion and one you can
try yourself very easily is you just
need three people the one behind is the
subject who's got his eyes closed and
his arm stretched out and his finger is
being held by the experimenter and the
one in front he's only needed for his
modes and what's happening is that the
experimenter is synchronously tapping
the nose of the one in front with a
finger of the subject and the nose of
the subject so from the subjects point
of view his eyes are closed he's out his
fingers like that he's feeding a nose
and he's feeding his own nose being
touched synchronously so we can all do
this there's no contradiction you can
touch your nose but touching your nose
with your arm out stretch is a
contradiction and the way the brain
solves this is it gives you this
illusion doesn't work on everybody but
for a large number of people you get
this illusion quite fast after this kind
of synchronous touch and as I left it if
you do the touching asynchronously it
doesn't work then the rubber hand
illusion
oh that's already spoken about
and also shown the video and the ad this
one also and I spoke about and I'll just
show the video of that because it also
has another aspect that you didn't see
so it's synchronous touching that the
subject is seeing the plastic body
substituting his own body through the
head-mounted display and what happens
when you cut the plastic body he's
seeing his plastic body cut and you get
a spike in arousal when that happens and
if the tapping she's doing now is a
synchronous this doesn't work so it's
another example of the multi-sensory
integration that gives us our body
representation now in virtual reality
the first reports of using Lee are in
representing the body were by a jaron
lanier in the night late 1980s and early
90s this wasn't like published
scientifically but he spoke about it at
conferences and he did strange things
like in body and yourself as a lobster
so when you see yourself when you're
wearing a head mount to display and you
look down towards your own body you see
a lobster body and since the 1990s
there's been many studies that
demonstrated an association between
having a virtual body and your sensor
presence in virtual reality the body is
also important in that when you have a
virtual body in virtual reality even if
it's a very simple one it it corrects
the distance judgments that you tend to
do wrongly in virtual reality
and then bailenson and Lee introduced
what they called the Proteus effect
which is concerned with how the type of
body or given in virtual reality
influences your behavior and their idea
is that it's through the reflection of
how it's perceived that to be evaluated
by others they have a kind of social
psychological perspective and as you've
seen in cognitive neuroscience since the
publication of the rubber hand illusion
in 1998 especially there's been a huge
interest of in research about how does
the brain represent the body and virtual
reality is an excellent tool in this
regard so one of the first things we did
actually together with old life is we
embodied men
in the body of a female body using
multi-sensory integration where the
subjects saw if they look down of
themselves in in the mirror they saw
this female body and they saw another
avatar stroking their shoulder and what
we did is we synchronously stroked the
real shoulder of the subject where while
they were doing that and they tended to
get this strong Body Transformation
illusion and we've embodied people as
children and we've also embodied people
as adults and the technique we tend to
use although we can use visual touch
synchrony what we find actually is more
powerful with visual motor synchrony so
here's someone wearing a head-mounted
display their body motion is being
captured in real-time they look down at
themselves they see a virtual body they
see also in the mirror and as they move
the body moves the same and this tends
to produce a strong perceptual illusion
of ownership of that body even though
cognitively they know is not true they
know it's not their body but it's like
any visual illusion if you shut your
eyes it goes away but if you don't you
can't but help have that illusion what's
even more interesting than that is that
changing the body representation can
lead to changes in perception attitudes
and behavior so I'm going to talk today
about racial bias but we've also also as
Anna mentioned becoming a child you can
even give people the illusory agency
that if their virtual body does
something that they either they didn't
do that they will have the illusion that
they did it so we've done all that kind
of thing but now I want to concentrate
on implicit racial bias so first of all
what's implicit racial bias its measured
by a test called the IAT test the
implicit implicit association test a
racial bias and basically the way it
works is that if in a fast reaction time
test you compare up dark faces with
negative words and light faces with
positive words faster than the other way
around
dark faces of positive words like faces
of negative words then it is an
indication of bias it's a response time
measure it's not a questionnaire
by the way implicit bias doesn't mean
that the person is prejudiced but it
reflects an implicit bias was more
likely to actually be socially
determined he doesn't it's not a
reflection of your beliefs and but on
the other hand I a to see scores do
correlate with real-life behavior in
other words unconscious behavior like
you go on a bus and who do you choose to
sit next to unconsciously so how it
works actually I'll show you this way is
that this first I'll show very briefly
how it works so that's important that
you see on the screen like here in the
middle of the screen is a white white
child face and you have to press the
right button if you think it's if you
decide it's a white face or the left
button if you think is African American
you go through this again with the whole
series of faces in an early part and
then you do the same with words so you
have honest here you would press the
right button because it's a pleasant
word but if the word was rotten you'd
press the left button it's an unpleasant
word and then the test starts mixing
these two together here we see a white
child face you would press the right
button and then I haven't shown it but
there's a subsequent one where they
cross these over and you have African
American with Pleasant and European
American with unpleasant and again you
depending on the word or the face you
see you have to press the left or right
button so it's a reaction time test so
in our first experiment we had four
groups of 15 females of all European
white females they were embodied in
either a dark-skinned body or a
light-skinned body or no body or in a
purple body to check that any results we
had would not just due to difference but
due to race and first of all they had
this I 18 measure and then a few days
later they had the virtual reality
exposure and then straight away after
that they had another measure of the
implicit association test so these are
just the conditions they were either
embodied and white body a dark skinned
body a purple body or nobody and the
only thing that ever happened is some
characters will pass them six white and
six
so it's a really simple experiment
really simple setup so she's just
wearing a virtual-reality so there was
no task
she just had to look at her body look
around here she sees it in the mirror
and that's all twelve minutes of that
and some characters walk by and that's
all that happens so these are the
results of the subjective body ownership
that they're high except for the note
embodiment condition but more important
than that this is the difference between
the posts and pre IAT
and as you can see only in the dark skin
condition there's the implicit
association test for racial bias measure
go downwards then we did another
experiment where we repeated this we are
interested in mainly does the effect
hold for one week because last time we
did the measurement immediately after so
here we had three groups the IAT measure
before anything in one week later they
had the exposure and then one week after
that we measured the IAT again the
second group they had two exposures and
then one week after that the IAT measure
and the third week three thirds group
three exposures one week after that the
IAT measure these are all females from
University of Barcelona and there were
90 of yeah 90 together and these are
I'll just show you in the video so sorry
I'll move it forward to be so they wear
the suit and then they go in the virtual
reality and this is someone embodied in
the dark-skinned body and they're told
to first of all look around and move and
look in the mirror and then there's a
Tai Chi Tai Chi
teacher there who does the movements and
they're told copy in the movements of
the Tai Chi teacher or they could be
embodied in a white body and exactly the
same the Tai Chi is only there because
they have to come several times some of
them and it's like a reason why they
would come because they learning Tai Chi
and also it's to make them move just to
make them move and look in the
so again the subjective body ownership
is very high when there's this is
comparing this is my body compared with
I have the feeling of two bodies it
doesn't matter with whether in a black
body or a white body or if it's the
first second or third session this is
comparing my body in the mirror it's my
body compared with the features of their
bodies if my body does he look like me
and obviously it looks a bit more like
than if it's the white body but
otherwise the scores are low but again
more interesting we see the same pattern
that whether they had one two or three
exposures it goes the IAT goes down in
one condition
and in the first week again we get the
same pattern those were and you had one
exposure it goes up in the white body
the last one I want to show is to do
with people in social harmony they tend
to unconsciously mimic each other this
is a well-known finding in social
psychology that if you see like if
you're in a restaurant you can tell
which couples are getting on because
they're doing a going to dance together
that they move in synchrony much more
than people who are not in harmony so
what we did is we had two groups of
sixteen they're either embodied in a
white body or a black body and then one
week they interacted with a white
virtual partner the next week and then
waited one week and the next week with a
black virtual partner or the other way
around
black virtual partner one week and white
virtual partner the other they had no
idea what we were doing we were actually
measuring the number of times they
copied the movements of the virtual
partner so we are measuring the number
of mimicry events and it's very simple
it just looks like this they're talking
with another character they're
describing some photos on the wall and
we measure how many times occasionally
the other partner the virtual partner
does some move right put their hands
together or scratch their hear or
scratch their arm we just counted how
many times the subject copied back and
it moved to this one for the interest of
time when they have different skin color
they do less mimicry than when they have
the same skin color so if I'm embodied
as black and my partner is black my
virtual partner is like I
tend to copy her or him more than I
would if I'm black and my partner's
white and similarly for both white
so the mimicry is really powerful
because you could say with the IHC test
well they know it's about rape because
you've given them a test beforehand but
here they have no clue what it was that
we are measuring so these racial bias in
the interest of time I just say these
racial bias results they've been
replicated now more than four times like
another group led by men our security in
London showed the same effect using a
black rubber hand rather than a whole
virtual body there's been various other
studies as well so now towards the model
we have input from the environment and
we have people categorized as out group
and in group here it would be with
respect to race we have pleasant and
unpleasant categories pleasant or
unpleasant attributes of those and from
society we tend to get the or from it
from our input we tend to get positive
correlations between our in group and
pleasant attributes and negative
correlations between our out group and
unpleasant attributes and negative sorry
positive correlation between out group
and unpleasant cuts attributes the red
ones are negative correlations this is
built up as associations in our brain
over many years and when you do these
response time measures basically we're
sampling those associations on the other
hand we do in relation to ourself we
tend to attribute if we have reasonable
self-esteem we tend to attribute
pleasant attributes to ourselves could
have Pleasant attributes to others but
if you measure response times about
yourself with pleasant attitudes or
other words other others with pleasant
attributes the response times to
yourself would normally be faster now
when you take those two models and you
add them together this is how I think
that the racial bias test works that
basically the response when you embody
yourself as black you're then bringing
out attributes to yourself and combining
that with the
attributes of the out-group because yet
now your embodies is the out-group and
it modulates the response times and I
did a simulation of this using a very
simple linear model based on that
previous diagram using gamma distributed
response times and we reproduce the same
results that we saw and people at
University College London in the
cognitive neuroscience institute they
built a neural network model based on
this idea based on the idea of resonance
between yourself and out-group here with
respect to skin color so it's a very
simple model where you have two neurons
one leading to left one leading to
choosing the right button and these are
in conflict with one another because
it's a fourth choice test you either
choose the left button and right bang
you got sensory input coming in
determining which of those two buttons
would be pressed and basically the top
of the two neurons that represent
congruent and incongruent choices so
here we see likely we've got positive
association as positive correlation
between positive attributes and light
skin on the left hand side and positive
action and dark skin and negative
attributes and in the uncle incongruent
condition in the IAT test it swapped the
other way around
so when you build the neural network
like this and training on the data from
the actual experiments and then run a
simulation you're using the neural
network you reproduce the same results
we got in the study so both for the pecs
study the very first one we did in 2013
and the more recently we had published
in 2016 with the multiple with E when we
measured the IAT one week after you're
using the neural network built by the
UCL group we find the simply similar
results obtained so conclusions the way
the Twitter a I worked was like a brain
in of that connected to everything the
learning was based on all the inputs it
got without any kind of differentiation
so a racist coming was judge equivalent
to comment about cricket or football
like that everything was the same with
which group did that AI are
self-identified what personal
self-esteem does it have these are
issues that should be included in the
design of these things in a sense what
I'm saying is give the AI a body
resonating with a social group that you
desire and that body might be similarity
of profiles of other Twitter users
pictures photographs contents of their
tweets and so on and maybe that way the
racist blahblah might be able to be
reformed so this is a knowledge meant to
the to the funding and there's of course
being many people involved and again I'd
like to thank Mark for inviting me to
this because it's made me think about
some things we were doing in a different
way Thanks thank you okay thank you
so we are now going to move into the
question circle so I will ask the
speakers to come here
so just summarizing a bit I think we
have talked about very deep perception
mechanisms and so maybe it's one of
music we have data as a job analysis so
we have seen examples of perception from
a very deep sensory level to a
multi-sensory level and consciousness
level and finally how this perception
change behavior so I'm wondering if
there are any questions here we can talk
about for I think maybe but I have some
questions myself so I think one of the
learnings that I was hoping elicit from
these talks the first one is that we
need to be building multi-sensory
systems and we need to understand that
behavior derives in a very strong way
from perception what I wonder now is if
the neuroscientist here in the panel
believe there are like critical aspects
that they think it's missing right now
for example on the speech assistance or
self-driving cars or from getting into
these new levels of behavior and and
extended perception into consciousness
or some of these aspects maybe I can try
to start so I think what what Mel
mentioned I think resonated well with me
also give it a buddy so I think if
artificial intelligence systems would
have a body that that can be linked to
bodily processing as as it is in humans
and can be tested I think this would be
hopefully value of value for I I but
that that's you more the expert
definitely for us it would be
be interesting and and I mentioned well
mail would have to say more about both
but social biases and and so on but I
think one one way forward of giving it a
body in the sense that you mentioned it
could could be that these systems may
also have a rudimentary form of
self-consciousness maybe and I think
this would be an exciting idea okay we
have some questions
Bruce Walker from Georgia Tech I'm
wondering if it's not only or it's not
only about a body but about a self in
this that could be lost and wondering
whether AI needs to incorporate the
sense of self-preservation and doing
things that are you know a lot of what
we do is the biological functions of
self-preservation but also the social
self-preservation
we're not rude and we're not engaging in
the the chatbot kind of behavior for a
lot of reasons some of which are there
may be they may be reducible to the
cost/benefit function but I don't see
that being incorporated yet in in in the
AI kind of models nice somebody wants to
want a bit larger so you were referring
more to cognitive models of self or
cognitive aspects of self like relate to
personality is is that the direction you
would be going and so the notion at
least for me that I present it would be
like a conscious very low-level
bottom-up a system of a conscious self
and I think then on a pure neuro
scientific point of view one of our
hypotheses is that this is something
that's shared across many animals so
it's the simplest form of self that can
we can become aware of and then
higher-level forms of self related to
language related to cognition related to
visual self or Commission in a mirror
for example would be built on on top of
this but I mean in the end they're not
separate systems they're all closely
interlinked to some extent reinforcement
learning does have that because it
learns by penalty through penalties and
it kind of in a sense has a body which
is its long term low and self
preservation in some sense could be
built into that so I'd see reinforcement
learning at perhaps a rich area for for
exploring that kind of thing yeah yeah
Wonderland also dad from the Volusia
nari perspective in many cases
preservation
it's a goal because you have a prey or a
predator I mean I mean in terms of
artificial intelligence there is no
clear predator for you to behave in a
certain way or prevent certain actions
and they clearly reinforcement learning
like faking it or like introducing these
rules so learning by example works if
they're examples in with your make
mistakes that prevent you from
continuing but I don't think that well
in the case of self-driving cars of
course there will be examples that
prevent you from continuing but other AI
systems might not introduce that kind of
errors okay we have another question
Beth miner also from Georgia Tech
promise it's not a mob I'm wondering if
these perceptual illusions are amplified
or washed out in environments that have
a stronger narrative around them and if
anyone is looking at that we did work at
Georgia Tech with digital media on an
augmented reality experience called
three Angry Men we couldn't afford to do
12 Angry Men but for those of you
familiar with the film it was you were
in the jury room seated at a table you
could feel the table and you could
experience the viewpoint of the
different characters and by standing up
and changing the seats you would assume
their body but not with these types of
illusions attached to that but you would
hear their inner monologue and we
actually filmed it such that the
characters would reinforce the racial
stereotypes that were present in that so
if we kind of added these virtual body
illusions would that amplify that type
of dramatic experience which is really
looking at targeting kind of a racial
empathy and understanding yeah I think
that's a very important question that
there's actually two aspects to it one
is the illusion of body ownership itself
so when we do
when we do these kind of studies human
body adults as a child or white people
as black people or the other way around
the the level of body ownership is
always high provided you have the right
multi-sensory integration whether it's
visual touch visual motor or whatever it
is or all of those combined combined but
what we've never tested is when the
subject has M antipathy to the body
which they inhabit so you know the kind
of people we do the studies are a well
they're people in Spain and there's not
like this very deep level of racial bias
that they might be in some other
countries so what would happen if you
took someone in the case of racial bias
who is extremely explicitly prejudiced
they may not have this body ownership
illusion where they may not even do it
at all but we just don't know we haven't
explored that it's actually very
difficult to explore the other aspect of
it is is about that you mentioned about
narrative and there is evidence that
when you have a narrative that
counteracts the kind of thing I was
showing it does counteract it so Jeremy
bailenson I forget when they did a study
where they embodied white people in a
black body and black people in the black
body in a white body but they put in a
context of a job interview and a job
interview is known as one area where
racial bias is very if not consciously
unconsciously paramount and amongst all
the studies I've shown that there must
be maybe seven or eight studies now in
this racial bias area theirs is the only
one where they were the results when
exactly the opposite way and in one of
the ones we did where there's this
dialogue with the other person we find
this mimicry effect but there's no
implicit association effect unless you
take into account another Cove area
because the mimicry effect is like
itself is already a measure of the
unconscious behavior but the bias thing
doesn't work the same way as the ones I
showed and right now we're running an
experiment
well not right now cuz it's in the
middle of the night in Spain but we are
running an experiment to explicitly look
at the kind of thing you're saying where
there's a narrative you're embodied as
black areion bodies as white we want to
see what happens so it's the answer the
question is we don't know but I think
that it does have benefit you hi that's
John garage from USC a kind of related
question which is I'm you've shown so
the surprising plasticity of body
identity and I'm curious of other
examples where it sort of stubbornly
resists these kind of a manipulation so
whether certain constraints narrative
was mentioned as just one where you just
can't seem to overcome people resist
these kind of illusions so maybe from
neuroscience perspective you can comment
on the prevalence of illusions that
don't alter behavior and then maybe and
as you can comment on that yeah so in
any way loses how they describe it there
is some people that don't experience
really loosens and we were wondering
what is happening there may be many many
possible explanations but one the one
that we were loading is people that are
more the word of their bodies and other
people so we're looking at interoceptive
awareness well if you are better in
detecting your internal body signals
this is that people that are more aware
of their body they resist more these
external influence on the other side
that is studies for example with people
with anorexia or so that they actually
are more influenced by these resolutions
they say less attention to their body
signals and reliable understand and
information so that's that one of the
yeah I think it's interesting that we
know that the prevalence on the
multi-sensory integration is is not even
a hundred percent so even when you get
into the narrative or
of course even drops more or like you
might encounter cases of more rejection
or maybe meld you found even well there
is another example because both Anna and
I separately she mentioned the study of
the long arm using sound and we did one
with vision and I think we both found it
breaks down after the virtual arm is
three times the length so it worked up
to three times the length you still got
the illusion it was your arm
the knot four times the length it was
three was your cutoff its way so maybe
there's some kind of geometric
boundaries as well of some topological
boundaries to what you can do I would
also add like it really depends how long
you're exposed to these scenarios
imagine living your entire life with an
arm which is really ten times as long
probably the brain will learn to
integrate also these dynamic simulations
I think it I think one striking thing is
really that many of these illusions are
the exposure is a minute or two minutes
how can something of a minute or two can
overcome a lifelong experience of what
my my my my hand is compared to this
this these different arm conditions you
have so I think if the exposure would be
longer and consistent I think we
embodiment with with many many objects
not even just bodily look an object is
probably possible we sorry before we
move to the next question I think there
on might have something to say fire to
be question
Anthony horn off University of Oregon
missing from a lot of this discussion
here or entirely missing from this
discussion is a concept of cognitive
strategy and it seems to some extent
this work is embracing a notion of going
straight from perception to action
without a decision-making process in the
middle and this gets a bit too Bruce
Walker's comment with regards to
self-preservation people do make
cognitive strategies based on a goal of
self-preservation and sometimes the best
strategy might be a counterintuitive
strategy and this can easily explain why
the behavior flips in the job interview
situation people in those situations
simply choose to take a different
cognitive strategy thesis maybe I know
you can comment below some so I think
from the perspective of for example
before you were talking about sensory
motor actions how prediction mechanisms
play roles and and I think from the
action perspective and action binding
perspectives from the neuroscience like
basic neuroscience before we go to
behavioral because I really like to this
this kind of different tables because
one can be more consciously manipulated
but they most be sensory axiom binding
mechanisms are also very interesting so
I want to drop down to on a first-year
and I was going to say that I don't I
have you also that is in my happiness
and different limits so yeah
while talking our sensorimotor notes we
will have our predictions and then we
are just if they are some discussed
discrepancies with century outputs now I
will get diamine I started
representation talking about sensory
systems being their primary function is
to to preserve us to have keep a
constant Melina safety and that may
happen and will have these low level
processes that of course also make
decisions constantly that allow us to be
moving okay I agree with I guess
consciousness slight great wrong here a
quick response I mean it's a good
comment and of course our design to try
to exclude cognitive biases as or
top-down process as much as possible
starting from attention and and many
other aspects so so so in a sense by the
design we're trying to exclude and what
we're starting to to look at is
confidence also so so how confident am I
about my judgment whether is the
questionnaire score or let's say this
this recalibration response where my
center of awareness is and and then one
starts to get into some of these
cognitive processes and again and these
these metacognitive judgments about
confidence have mostly been made about
you know moral decisions visual
decision-making auditory and so so we're
actually seeing interesting effects they
know it's mine it's multi-sensory there
seems to be different contents for these
different modalities and how they
integrate it but it's an important point
and I think if you would integrate this
into your experimental setup having one
condition where you have a strong
cognitive file and then not you'll
probably recover those but we haven't
specifically targeted so they are
involved in all these so-called even
low-level I insisted very much that this
is very low-level bottom-up signal
integration but of course this nothing
is closed in you know in a way in the
brain so these systems are open and
accessible to these mechanisms yeah I
wanna add a bit dots on that there must
be shape around so when you start
working more on behavioral a you start
having learning so learnings are over
time and that's kind of also AI problems
that
you have to perceive things overtime
experiments or short periods but men for
example hard work goes on only longer
exposures and how that affects overtime
which has to do with a lot with how you
prepare for an action with respect to
our sensory input door so yeah you're on
you have a comment here like we should
put a chair here for you and you wanted
it if you could design a vert reality
version of Twitter and you wanted to
maximize maximize the human lack of blah
blah
to paraphrase how what would it look
like
Wow next question sorry question I think
is worth something but something
spending a little time thinking about
because it has to be done right here we
know the consequences of it but the
simple idea I mean the basic idea always
tried to write in my last slide is you
needn't be a body but of course actual
vert about your body but that you want
your Twitter agent to have
characteristics which resonate with us
let's say the social group of the
political group of whatever it is that
you want it to be like so it that could
actually even be a picture of a face or
it could be a virtual body and it
compares itself with when it receives a
tweeting from somebody else it compares
itself with the characteristics of that
person as part of its evaluation of
whether it should deny that statement or
agree with it or make no comment so this
is the resonance idea that are more
likely to agree with someone who
resonates in some sense whatever that
definition of resonate happens to be in
that domain
no no it's I mean the rich variety is
rich variety is good but there's like
let's say you don't want your presumably
we don't our Twitter agents to resonate
with Nazis one way to distinguish is
that you have a set of characteristics
you compare your characteristics were
theirs whether those characteristics are
when in that case it wouldn't be
physical but it will be like statements
they've made or things about themselves
or the history of their previous tweets
and if my ones are more like less like
there's the less chance is that I would
say yeah you're right yeah and whatever
they say this is the kind of thing I
mean it's not to deny variety but it's
to choose where you want to place
yourself in that variety and why I only
have one AI chatbox there could be
several of it represent different points
of view as well okay last question yeah
so this may be kind of follows on the
previous line of discussion a little bit
I'm thinking about the distinction
between the explicit and the implicit
and where you as researchers are always
kind of the explicit one here you have
some kind of question of some like set
of values you're hoping to impart
implicitly through these interventions
and it's kind of a dichotomy but I'm
wondering if you can think about that
more spectrally or how you compare what
you're doing to more explicit
interventions where somebody would
observe their own bias and yeah and it's
not completely formed but I thought it
might be some prompt for discussion
maybe Jana it's it's very interesting
just thinking more about it I think as
you said we're trying to have different
kind of measurements during the process
or immediately after the process we call
the questionnaire has already explicit
and then this recalibration that say or
heartbeat related changes would be an
implicit matter of measurement but I
think exposed exposing people like
almost in a form of therapy or
afterwards or to their responses whether
it's therapy or not I think would be
would be interesting again going back to
the point so this is again open then to
more cognitive aspects that we as a lab
have been less interested in or less
pursued but I think to study those
interactions which will likely be
multiple whether there's a verbal let's
say explicit intervention or whether
there is a spatial or purely visual one
I think there will be different
mechanisms that allow to - also need to
changes yes actually mentioning therapy
also throws light on on the question so
let's take the case server like clinical
psychology someone has a fear of heights
and the clinician tells them well it's
because when you were five years old you
will buy a height with your mother and
your mother got really scared and this
gave you an immediate phobia that's not
going to change anybody but if you do
some implicit intervention procedures
that's much more likely to change
someone than knowing the explicit
knowledge of what caused their problems
okay and that it for today in this
session I want to thank our speakers
it's been great to have you here
thank you for coming on and I hope you
enjoyed the rest of the systems on the
panel